wonderful to have you all with us back
here we've had many fruitful discussions
here throughout
the day and now this is the time to have
the grand finale to have the closing
remarks
to wrap up a very busy but content Rich
day ladies and gentlemen and now first
up without further Ado the prime
minister of Ukraine ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome again prime minister
Dennis schmeeha
foreign
president of European Commission
thank you all so much for this tough day
tough schedule
I believe and I know that this expert
and scientific discussions are very
productive very pragmatic very fruitful
and we have First Impressions and
they're very positive I hope that during
the next days we will have
this conclusions of our conference our
meetings annual health and we will have
very good advices have to continue
our work after lugana conference in
sense of recovery of Ukraine and
I think that this conference is logic
continuation of Uganda conference and is
beginning of our future big job big work
uh for Recovery of Ukraine for
modernization of Ukraine form an
organization all of Europe and maybe for
modernization of world and future so we
all together today create our future
for my country in direct sense our
future thank you all for this and I
would like to express my biggest
appreciation and big gratitude to core
host organizers
thank you so much for organization on
such a great event
I think that
expert expert level today was very high
and very good results will create next
steps next steps as for me should be on
the platform for coordination of
finances and maybe economical and other
coordination platforms but first of all
today we have a previous agreement to
organize Financial coordination platform
on the basis of j7 International
Financial organizations IMF
European Investment Bank oecd other
Financial organizations and our partners
which support Ukraine today as I told
United and support United and Recovery
it's one of the main principles which we
all approved in Lugano
so as today Chancellor Schultz noted
we all don't organize something for make
it like one's action we will have
continuation of our work we will have
coordination platform we will have on
board United States European Union our
j7 partners and all International
Financial organizations we understand
that we need prioritization and we
discussed this today that we need
support of budget deficit we need
financing of rapid recovery needs and
needs assessment we need recovery and
modernization of Ukraine and find this
key issues for modernization for next
years and maybe decades as also
Chancellor noted today during his speech
and I think that today's priorities are
very natural because today's during
these two weeks Russians destroy our
infrastructure electricity
infrastructure heating infrastructure
water supply and infrastructure creating
the biggest ever
humanitarian catastrophone on the
European continent and to stop this we
need unite our efforts and we need to
create something to resist of these
intentions of terrorist country Russia
we should protect our Energy Water
supplying heating we should find format
half very in very fast way to recover
infrastructural objects and we should
find altogether way how to protect our
infrastructure and civilian
infrastructure and critical
infrastructure so it's also very
important and I'm sure that during this
conference experts discuss these issues
and we also will have support and will
have concrete decisions from our
partners so once again for the
finishing of my speech my conclusions
thank you all who participate today who
spent this day who spent weeks for
preparation of this conference for
preparation of your conclusion your
advices to all experts to all Noble or
Lauria to all our partners to president
of Switzerland to polish prime minister
who are now not with us but participate
in this conference to all our friends
and partners thank you so much you're
all of jerusala thank you so much all
the best to you thank you
thank you prime minister for your
concluding remark you've already laid
out some of the steps that ought to be
or rather must be taking from here on
the German G7 presidency is ending at
the ends of the year and Japan is the
country that is going to take over the
torch starting at the beginning of next
year and the promise of Japan
unfortunately couldn't be here but he
didn't want to pass up the opportunity
to address this distinguished audience
and send us a video message for all of
you here on stage and in the audience so
let's have a look Prime Minister of
Japan fumio kishida was kind enough to
send us his message his words
let's see what he has to say
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
give us
foreign
give us
give us
this is
many thanks to Japanese prime minister
fumio kishida Forest works for the video
he submitted the country that is going
to take over the torch from Germany uh
at the beginning of next year we wish
them best of luck and it's clear from
his words that he's trying to and he
wants to use the momentum provided by
forums like these and make them flourish
and continue
um the uh right next is up the president
of a country that is currently holding
the presidency of the G20 in fact many
of you I can imagine will be at the G20
Summit in Bali next month and he also
didn't want to pass up the opportunity
to address this audience he's of course
Indonesian president Yoko vidodo and we
will hear from him now
young Mulia
France
I
thenkat
is
foreign
Hindi Khan
foreign
foreign
foreign
Kamali
foreign
foreign
trimagasi
thank you to Indonesian president Joko
vidodo for his remarks for his video and
he will see many of you in a little less
than a month in Bali to once again pick
up many of the issues that we've
discussed today and incorporate them
into the G20 Summit in Bali we're going
to wrap up this conference the way we
started namely of course with remarks
from or to co-host first up once again
please help me welcoming back on to the
podium uh none other than the president
of the European commission president
from the line you have the floor
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this this was an
excellent conference and I really thank
you for all the contributions all the
wisdom all the expertise that you
brought to the table
um the main message of the day for me
today is that Ukraine has everything it
takes for a successful reconstruction it
has determination
it has a vibrant Civil Society
many many friends around the globe who
want to support this was visible today
and an impressively resilient economic
base despite this atrocious War
for example the Ukrainian banking sector
or the I.T sector
for me always the level of
digitalization dear Dennis that you have
in Ukraine is impressive
listen to that after Estonia Ukraine is
probably the most digitized country in
Europe and that is something
this really allows public services to
function despite the war and this is our
daily experience in the commission when
we work together with you you have a
functioning Administration despite a war
around you and this is basically because
you're so much digitized
for topics that we have mentioned this
morning in the welcome addresses but
allow me to focus on a few takeaways
from today's discussion
the first one is give ownership to the
locals
creating trust in the Reconstruction
process
it was interestingly for me to hear that
the original Marshall Plan was
successful because independent experts
were embedded into Ministries
they ensure transparency over key
decisions
and we know money cannot solve
everything you need the right
institutions
so scrutiny so scrutiny is that was
interesting for me to monitor the
influence of donors
and Ukraine Civil Society is well
equipped to take over this world
my second
[Applause]
my second takeaway to tap into the full
power of Ukraine's human capital and to
accelerate the green and the digital
transition
there should be continuity of
decentralization
because the regions and the
municipalities are also economic
powerhouses
this decentralization
together with the necessary judicial
judicial and anti-corruption reforms
would of course also facilitate private
investment across the country
the third point
reconstruction linked with a dynamic
e-work session process
can function as a catalyst as it was
said today here for necessary reforms
and at the same time and this is
certainly true as a strong motivator to
implement these reforms because there's
a goal you want to go to and therefore
you understand why you have to do these
reforms
the first point self-explanatory and new
martial plan for Ukraine has to match
the European green deal this is the
opportunity to leapfrock into a modern
competitive and sustainable economy
I like the fifth point
that crossed my way donors coordination
should Prevail over donors competition
and the better the reconstruction plan
is explained the easier for donors to
contribute
finally
today
absolutely clear we saw that we will be
in this for a long time
support fatigue might be a challenge
but one participant brought up an
interesting counter argument
it is about the importance of
communication
she mentioned
that politics cannot
and should not be separated from the
Reconstruction process
Putin's brutality
is causing tremendous suffering and
destruction in Ukraine
but at the same time this ruthless Deeds
are backfiring
peoples disgust with Putin is a powerful
recruiter for Ukraine's Rehabilitation
efforts it fuels the new Marshall Plan
and then it's
I must say when I listened to you this
morning I was again really moved and
touched by the pictures the videos you
showed us I mean this is the reality on
the ground you are experiencing every
day but when you see it again it really
touches you and the way president
zielinski and you are communicating to
the public is contributing a lot to keep
Ukraine on top of the world's agenda and
to mobilize lasting support for your
country on the world stage and Ukraine
deserves it
[Applause]
thank you madam presidents for your
unambiguous and unve unwavering
commitment and support for Ukraine for
the recovery and reconstruction of your
country
prime minister and we're going to finish
a long day the way we started it namely
with remarks by the German Chancellor
the country that is currently holding
the G7 presidency and to help us put
this all together here in Berlin today
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome back
chairman Chancellor Olaf Schultz
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen first let me thank
all participants for joining us here
today for this important Global dialogue
in Berlin
my very special thanks to president
zelenski for addressing us this morning
and to prime minister smeagal on his and
his colleagues who are here with us
today and most importantly the people of
Ukraine
this has been an international expert
conference president from the line and I
sought to bring the best and brightest
Minds together to discuss with
delegations from around the world the
recovery and reconstruction of Ukraine
I'm happy to see the great interest also
from civil society and business as we
need all actors for a successful
recovery participation from all over the
world through our livestream shows
significant Global interest
today's discussion showed once again
that the size of the Reconstruction
challenge is impressive
the expert's contributions
provided proof that the core elements of
recovery reconstruction of modernization
are very closely linked with each other
therefore we need the guidance by
experts and as seen today it would
identify solutions to this complex
challenge
this conference has confirmed my
optimism I take from the panel
discussions that there are not only
challenges ahead
but also clear and coherent
recommendations and concrete ways to
actively create a better future for and
with Ukraine
tonight we have a better picture on
which factors are most important to make
the recovery and reconstruction of
Ukraine a success for Ukraine for Europe
and for the International Community
the recommendations which the experts
have developed over the last week's
voice today
will play a vital role now while our
Ukrainian colleagues will continue to
refine their National Recovery plan
the recommendations will now inform
ongoing International policy discussions
as International Community we will
continue to prepare the architecture for
a robust and inclusive governance
framework to guide our support
st7 presidency we will continue our work
on such a governance framework in close
coordination with the European Union
International organizations and other
partners in the G7 and Beyond and of
course with Ukraine as we have done
throughout our presidency this year
Lugano has been the starting point for
the recovery of Ukraine we have
continued this important work today and
we will continue to keep pushing forward
on this
let me assure you that also beyond the
end of our G7 presidency Germany will
continue to play a strong role to
support Ukraine where we can
and we are happy to confirm our offer to
host the follow-up Lugano conference in
24.
I close this conference by sharing with
you my conviction
which you have strengthened today
in light of the latest attacks now more
than ever the recovery of the peaceful
and prosperous Ukraine
is our joint endeavor
I'm convinced
that we are stronger together we
continue to stand together in supporting
Ukraine
as long as it takes
[Applause]
let me just say some concluding remarks
while you're standing here with me let
me just say this officially concludes
the international expert conference on
the recovery reconstruction and
modernization of Ukraine but I think it
is has become abundantly clear this is
not a one-time initiative quite on the
contrary this is just the beginning and
as Madam president said we are in this
in the long run the expertise let me
just say this also the expertise
generated today will be included in
existing formats such as the annual
Ukraine recovery reform conference
hosted by the UK next year and with that
Madam president and prime minister thank
you so much for a Content Rich very
rewarding and Inspira inspiring debate
and Conference may all the debate may
all the dreams may all the inputs come
true before too long thank you so so
much
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]